these are the death certificates of four
palestinian boys killed during the war
in gaza last summer
samir manama is a lawyer who works with
the palestinian human rights
organization
he's been gathering evidence of possible
war crimes
we're questioning people taking
photographs looking at medical reports
recording the names of all the victims
we're collecting all the evidence we can
each sheet in these boxes corresponds to
one human fate
few of these cases have been examined by
judges
if they have it's been in an israeli
military court
human rights activists see the
international criminal court as the only
chance to hold israeli commanders and
politicians accountable
it's the time to reconsider the issue of
accountability as long as we are talking
about war crimes it's not palestine
israel it's the victims the victims are
far than ever from achieving their
rights where to go
this is the only place
the bakker family hopes the icc agrees
to hear their case
it's tough for them to go back to the
beach where their ten-year-old son and
three of his cousins were killed last
summer
another son al-muntasir was injured and
remains traumatized
when i come here where the children were
killed
it's almost as if it just happened
i can barely look at the scene
it used to be a special place for me
since i'm a fishermen
the boys were playing here on july 16th
2014 when they were caught in an
explosion almond sir is still too
disturbed to talk about it
this is the immediate aftermath
eyewitnesses including foreign
journalists reported two explosions in
quick succession
they were believed to be shells fired by
the israeli navy who say they did fire
on hamas targets at the time
an israeli military court is currently
examining the case
but the bakar family and palestinian
human rights activists see the
international criminal court in the
hague as a better guarantee of justice
even if the case could take years